en manilva q puso el listón muy alto en
su elección de un nombre para el nuevo
consejo el cnl
un guiño al legendario consejo nacional
de la resistencia creado por charles de
gaulle para unificar los movimientos de
la resistencia en la segunda guerra
mundial y con el objetivo de reconstruir
francia tras un difícil periodo
electoral en el que macaco se impuso
ante su rival de extrema derecha
magangué penn y luego de un nuevo revés
al perder la mayoría parlamentaria el
presidente francés espera dar un impulso
a su segundo mandato con este nuevo cnn
un espacio de diálogo entre la mayoría
la oposición los sindicatos y los
ciudadanos en torno a cinco temas el
pleno empleo la educación el cambio
climático la salud y la vejez
el objetivo de este cnn es establecer un
diagnóstico común discutir las
limitaciones acordar el mejor enfoque y
un calendario se dará previamente a los
trabajos legislativos y de nuevo después
durante su aplicación
pero no es la primera vez que me
compromete a gobernar de una forma más
consensuada y sus oponentes son
escépticos sobre este nuevo organismo
varios sindicatos y los principales
partidos de la oposición se niegan a
participar he dicho desde el principio
que era un truco macrón ya no un
instrumento para saltarse el parlamento
no lo necesitamos la democracia es la
separación de poderes tenemos un
parlamento el poder legislativo que hace
la ley y un ejecutivo pero si lo
mezclamos todos en otro órgano con todo
tipo de participantes entonces se socava
el parlament es incluso en el bando de
makro hay dudas con algunos cuestionando
el sentido del consejo el ex primer
ministro de macro edward philip encontró
una buena excusa para eludir la primera
reunión un choque de itinerarios con un
viaje a canadá